what are you so nervous about
oh he's got a date same one again yeah
so why the nerves but you said the first
one went really well it did look I need
your opinions on a matter of etiquette
okay shoot
when is it appropriate for me to show
her my lightsaber it wasn't a metaphor
wait are you saying that she doesn't
know you're a geek how could she know
haha she just doesn't know the extent of
it yet I just don't know if I should
tell her now or wait a little longer I
don't want to scare her off should I
tell her now or later later
if you don't tell her now you're gonna
undermine everything you've tried to
build up in the meantime you need to
tell her now really do you want to
remind us all exactly how that worked
out for you last time that's not fair
that was a fluke a daring escape out of
the window of the bathroom of the
restaurants and a changed phone number
fluke damn it how was I supposed to know
about the traumatic comic-con experience
we know what got dragged took Comic Con
by a friend and there was a cosplay
incident you don't want the details nope
anyway the point is you don't want to
reveal the full geekdom at least not off
the bat you need to wait a little while
make sure that she gets to know you that
she likes you that she has a reason not
to run screaming that's just not fair to
her though it's like dating a born-again
Christian for six months and then
mentioning oh by the way I'm a
pro-choice pagan crackhead that's an
exaggeration
barely
okay thanks you guys have been so
helpful how do I look at least man
perfect oh man I need a life okay
wish me luck you know I find it
interesting that you failed to mention
the cosplay incident centered around a
certain bikini clad Klingon who really
should have left her Bob left at home if
she was gonna partake of blood wine oh
shut up if I hadn't said anything she
never would have recognized me